yeah
doesn't seem very fresh I'll be honest
so I give you a little taste young fer
tonight no no
oh my banshee
I think it's still crackling very much
alive still Trey fresh so name your best
price for ten thousand volts ten
thousand volts of finest quality grade a
yeah a but is difficult to shift and it
difficult to store if I get the revenue
man in there sniffing around what's the
best price 150 guineas gentleman put the
merchandise back on board to prepare to
sell hold on hold on hold on cuddles
it's 160 160 seeing as I'm feeling
particularly generous today I'll settle
for 200 200 okay you're having a laugh
huh oh yeah anything that has he been
saying that where the airs too thin
yeah you're being very rude
no any more 201 ie 200 that's not
negotiation I'm changing my number 185
today you're 200 from you you did yeah
you said 200 if I did you're a
ventriloquist okay 195 final offer
195 it is so with sales tax as let's see
200 brilliant put it in the back
oh good still simple
spell it P inca23jdt know that let's
leave it blank wait last night or this
morning you pick 192 pounds number of
alcoholic beverages consumed per week
why do you need to know that well they
want to know I'm sure that you want to
know a lot of things but I don't want my
intimate details auctioned off to the
highest bidder willy-nilly
I'll put zero marital status boss
profession irrelevant food allergies I'm
not gonna be in here are you allergic to
sticking-plaster Ludacris question I'm
the answer anymore these really do you
smoke stop it do you wear dentures madam
listen when was the last time you ate ah
a pertinent question at last yesterday
lunchtime thanks for asking out a tuna
sandwich toaster soggy but did you drink
the laxative solution yes
did it work it was as advertised did you
evacuate your bowels
I drank copious amounts of drain
cleaning fluid what followed was fact a
complete sir what I'm asking is if you
were shot okay
good it again and again it was like a
terrorist attack down there in the
darkness and the chaos that running and
screaming okay fine with me good would
you kindly do me the favor of explaining
this oh okay I'm guessing and just spit
bond here but uh looks like that Roman
dude got a little cocky and climbed over
into the wild west and that cowboy knows
Roman dude wants to take over his
territory so you rounded up a posse and
put him in the stockade
let's all laugh at me the comedy night
guard know is the answer
sarcasm back at ya with you a humor box
wasn't laughing pretending to laugh if
that's what you want some sort of Battle
of humor do you know I don't want no I
don't want a battle of humor no you
don't be a bloodbath nothing funny about
Little Bighorn no I find it about as
funny as a fan cyst it's not funny okay
and I will not stand for this type of
blatant if I'm not clear tell me am i
clear
yeah yeah the dog is talking well it's
not the sort of thing you've missed is
it really a small handsome dog talking
anyway I've been assigned to protect you
so give me five yes you should have
we had no idea the timekeeper wanted it
we're just dumb kids why do we have to
watch the baby
technically arm work sometimes you're
the dog sometimes you're the baby
entertainment center
take no time
now on YouTube I'm just pulling your leg
pretty I shouldn't be driving
I don't care pretty bottom
[Music]
Scott
all right do me a favor let me do the
talking do not puke in front of an
officer of W at the puke cuz that'll
make me cute me more hello officer how
are you well I'm relieved you're not a
couple of black guys it's much higher
probability that I'd be jumpy shoot you
without provocation and then I could
lose my weapon that's good I don't want
to go to jail he doesn't wanna go to
jail have you been drinking and
operating this motor vehicle yeah a lot
well then you're probably going to jail
I'm gonna need you to breathe into this
for me officer you don't need to do that
I'm gonna say the judging by the look of
this car you can't afford my bribe why
how much do you charge 5500 why it's too
much are they what why so high I have an
expensive cocaine habit but you know
it's more than that I feel like when I
set the price up high it takes it out of
the realm of petty crime and helps me
preserve my sense of personal integrity
so a feeling of Southworth if you're
yeah it was nice chatting with you
anywho I'm still gonna need you to
breathe into this funny are you gonna
want to blow not suck there
oh yeah that's pretty much off the
charts you're drunk you're going to jail
step out of the vehicle I don't want to
sir I'm gonna ask you to exit the
vehicle one more time might as well
please get drunk yourself please get
back in the car listen to walk aside
he's not drunk I've made a terrible
mistake I I do this sometimes I get a
little it's the adrenaline over and
through well actually it arouses me
sexually oh I'm so sorry please please
let me help you be can you forgive me
did you eat something is it food poison
try
that was awesome
it stopped laughing if we're gonna be
gonna be fine it's all good
where we going to get rich